[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
and welcome back to the leia highlands
show today we're actually talking about
one of my favorite topics we're talking
about privacy coins and how that's gonna
look
in the future but before we jump in this
is powered by icon plus so as usual i'm
gonna do a really quick news
announcement so
icon has launched its next level d5
money market
it's called om finance and it actually
allows d5 users
um and yield farmers and also really
interesting non-crypto users
to earn extra yield so that's really
exciting um and this means open finance
for everyone
i also want to say thank you to block
five because they are
my sponsors i use them i earn 8.6
percent interest on my ustc so that's
really cool so
i'm going to put the just uh a link to
the um
to the website for you guys where you
can actually grab 25
if you sign up i'll put that in the
description i'll put it in
the the comment section so just go for
it and grab your 25
so like i said today we have a very
exciting guest we have somebody
with quite an interesting name it is of
course fluffy
pony how you doing ricardo
i'm great and uh thanks so much for
having me yeah
it's good to have you i have to say that
your name is
incredibly interesting and you must get
this
all the time so before we talk about
monero which by the way i'm a huge fan
of
i want to just get the basics behind the
name fluffy pony
sure so contrary to popular belief it's
not actually my real name
it is a nickname that was given to me
by two girls i worked with sure
like two decades ago who called
themselves fluffy puppy and fluffy bunny
and they gave me the moniker fluffy pony
and i thought at one point that i could
not use it that i could
walk away from it but they just didn't
let me they just
kept using it and i was like well that's
it i am
henceforth known as fluffy pony i think
it's good i think it's different
it's unique and it's i think it's great
for the branding and everything i think
it's brilliant
well i mean it's one thing that i i have
enjoyed about it
is it has been quite disarming to people
um they're not sure whether to take me
seriously and that's great because i
don't you know
typically i don't want to be taken
seriously i i enjoy
having fun and joking around and
i feel like if i was like professor
doctor mr spanie
yes or whatever that it would just be
it just wouldn't be true to who i am
it's true actually
because when we first connected um
somebody sort of tagged you in something
that i posted and then
immediately fluffy pony it just sounds
so endearing i wasn't
you know i wasn't just like oh shall i
be careful with this one it's super
endearing
thanks i appreciate that yeah of course
so you are part of the core monero team
is that right yes so i've uh i was the
lead maintainer on monero for
a very long time uh last year i stepped
back i still am a maintainer
i'm still heavily involved in the
community um but
you know i sort of stepped back from a
lot of the duties uh
largely to give other people an
opportunity to step in
um and not to be a bus factor you know i
didn't want to be
like that that thing that could be taken
out
that would disrupt things you know and i
don't want people looking up to me for
news or information or any indication
about what's going to happen with monero
manero is a
it's something that's driven by a
collective and
i think that that you know true to form
um
it's now even more driven by a
collective and there's no single hint
uh you know engine in it or like
you know pin that you can pull out and
everything collapses
right and i want to get to that because
that kind of links to
bitcoin in some way so we'll get to that
but what are you up to then at the
moment if you're not
um if you've taken a step back
sure so you know apart from being
involved in several boating accidents
in which i lost all of my uh
cryptocurrency sadly
you know don't go voting with private
keys um
i have actually what was this
have you not heard about the many voting
acts but what do you mean many i've
heard
once you're telling me there's more oh
there has to i mean there has to be any
time that i might have accumulated
uh cryptocurrency of any sort be it
bitcoin or other
i will definitely have successively had
a boating accident
oh my gosh one of those things you know
and not the only person many people have
had boating accidents with their private
keys on them
sadly their private keys are now forever
lost bottom of the ocean
oh my gosh wow that's crazy so it's
happened multiple times to you
oh definitely yes i mean i always bring
my private keys on boats with me
oh my god are you not gonna not do that
next time like are you not or is this
just something you still do
i mean like i think it's just i think
it's just
good form to bring your private keys
with you
when you know there's a high risk of a
boating accident
you know and then it's gone
then it's gone forever and it's a tax
write-off you know which is
like so sad damn i'm really sorry to
hear about that that sucks
everybody sucks i'm sad as well
i cry myself to sleep many nights
thinking about
all of the private keys at the bottom of
the ocean
so i'm really in lakes you can leave
private keys on lakes as well
yeah well there you go so other than
losing private keys and
leaving them at the bottom of lakes and
oceans what are you up to
well the other thing that i'm working on
is tari which is a decentralized assets
protocol that we're building
um on top of monero or as a as a side
chain on monero
and we sort of view the the world of the
future as being
very assets focused i mean it already is
you know like kids play fortnite and
they're obsessed with like their v-bucks
and their skins and
other fortnight things you can you can
tell i've never played fortnite in my
life
meaning that you know and and
and so they already live in a world we
already live in a world where digital
assets are sort of
you know pretty common um but they're
they're largely
enclosed uh behind walled gardens
um and a classic example of this of
course is like airline loyalty points
um back when we used to be able to
travel
um then we used to collect these things
called airline loyalty points
and uh back then they used to be able to
travel yeah in the olden days yeah
all the days when air travel
and we did everything virtually um but
but airline loyalty points you know if
you
if you have like tons of emirates
loyalty points you can spend them on
emirates flights and that's it and uh
and there's there's like this weird
secondary market that's come to exist
with uh
some loyalty point systems where you can
go on like
um whatever ebay and buy someone else's
loyalty points
um because like you know you might be 50
loyalty points short of that
flight upgrade or whatever so you know
what we we're sort of imagining or
envisioning a world where
um those systems become a little bit
more open where
we can use decentralized um
or distributed technology to try and
break
down those walls where emirates
shouldn't care
how you acquired your points or you know
uh if you
no longer want them and you want to sell
them um you know and they will it might
mean that they that they need to think a
little bit more carefully about the
distribution mechanism but ultimately
it's great for them because they're able
to to still use the points
um to like like get new people and
acquire new
new flyers and those people are able to
go and like
turn those points into cash and it
applies to a whole bunch of other things
you know tickets
and of course nfts which are now all the
rage
um you know four or five minutes before
they explode and then no one cares
anymore
but it's uh it's definitely a space that
we're deeply interested in
and the space that we think is has got a
long future ahead of it
and i think monero is a really
interesting one um because people are
very
um sensitive when we talk about
different cryptos you know i think it
often has quite um religious undertones
honestly
um when people have seriously people are
very passionate
i'm right it was spot on it is it is so
close to religious fundamentalism
um and it's to the point where it's
embarrassing actually
you know like the the the it's not even
tribalism it it
is borderline religious fundamentalism
and if you take a look at stuff like bsv
where you know craig wright sort of
fashions himself as a god
who who wrote the the white paper and
now the hallowed white paper that
everyone must follow
it is it's just crazy it turns it into
almost like a cult um yeah and i think
that that's just
it's not a good not a good look it's a
technology it's not a
you know we shouldn't we shouldn't turn
it into a into this weird like
pseudo-religious cult no i'm totally
with you and the reason i bring it up is
because it's really interesting to see
how
people actually even bitcoin max millis
will
take an interest in monero so i kind of
wanted to get your opinion on that and
sort of understand what is it about
monero that actually
spikes the interest of bitcoin
maximalists
that's a good question um i i don't know
i think
i think part of it is that monero is
is interesting from a privacy
perspective and
you know a lot of bitcoiners um do care
about privacy
uh i also think it's interesting because
it's not
it's it's not like this cheap shot at
bitcoin where
um you know you click the fork button on
github
change some things and go oh look i
created a a new
a new cryptocurrency it's a totally
separate code base to bitcoin so from
that perspective it's interesting too
um and i think that there's a lot of you
know
what's really interesting from a design
perspective with monero and when i say
design i mean like
programmatic and architectural design is
um you can see the the people that
created
um kryptonite and monero's code base
they looked at what bitcoin had done and
a lot of the design decisions there and
they were inspired by it and they were
like
this is a good design decision let's
take that and use it
whereas a lot of other cryptocurrencies
have been created
um over the past uh you know sort of
five-ish years or so
um have gone like well bitcoin does it
this way let's do something completely
different
for no reason other than we don't want
to do things the bitcoin way
which is you know it's a little bit
crazy to me because
like bitcoin is not only the og but
like it's withstood the tests
and attacks over the past decade
and for that alone we should be looking
at it
um inspirationally if we're designing a
new system
right and you're referring to proof of
work versus proof of stake right
because that's one thing absolutely yeah
proof of work
versus proof of stake is one aspect um
even other things you know like ethereum
um rewarding uh blocks that are mined
that are that are not successfully mined
so orphan blocks
that whole system that the game theory
around that is so
outside of like the the game theory that
we know and understand with bitcoin
um other things like uh you know
ethereum
and others uh opting to use account
balances that update
versus bitcoins and moneros transaction
outputs
um you know the these are they're design
decisions but
like there's a very real reason why uh
bitcoin may
while why satoshi made those design
decisions in the first place
um and you know a decade later those
design decisions just
should be re like or should be
reinforced as being valuable
um and i guess it's a little bit of like
a non-invented year syndrome that i see
in the industry
like we you know we can't do things the
bitcoin way because
like heaven forbid we even acknowledge
that bitcoin exists that would be bad we
need to do things as differently as
possible
which is right right so so it
i think it's also kind of like book
maybe also because bitcoin is bitcoin
so in some ways it's kind of hard to
compete with so why so don't try and
compete with it try and do something
different i think that might be
also something going on there um
yeah but also there are a lot of other
privacy coins out there
z coins z cash you know whatever it is
so
from a monero perspective obviously
you're far more
bullish on monero and so on so why would
you prefer monero to things like
z coin z cash what how would you sort of
weigh them up against each other
that's a great question so the way i see
it is
um it really comes down to two things um
when you're when you're comparing
different privacy enhancing technologies
and by the way this doesn't only apply
to comparing privacy enhancing
cryptocurrencies
you can take the same thing and you can
apply it to comparing privacy enhancing
routing like
tor and itp and freenet and others
so the two principles i look at is first
the uh is privacy the default
now with any system you can opt out and
that's true of monero
as well so if you make a monaro
transaction you're like
look at my cool monero transaction it's
so private and you go post the details
on facebook
well you know it's no longer private
congratulations
um so it's there's there's no prevention
or no way
from a technological perspective to
prevent people from opting out of the
privacy system
but if it's the default it means that
you're at least
protected for the most part unless you
go and do something stupid
like post your transaction details on
facebook so so
default privacy is a very very critical
element
the second element that i look at which
i think is very important
is um how big is the pool of privacy how
big is the privacy set
so as an example you can imagine and we
see it
in the movies all the time the someone's
after the spy
and uh he's running through a
marketplace and he grabs a hat and he
grabs a jacket
and he disappears into the crowd right
now you can imagine if he disappears
into the crowd but the crowd is only
like four people
you know the bad guys the the russian
gangsters or you know whatever are gonna
come around the corner and they're gonna
be like
there he is and then they'll shoot at
him because like it's easy to see
whereas if he disappears into a crowd of
like three thousand people well they run
around the corner and they're like ah
let's go drink vodka and i think that
that's
that's really important you know so
default privacy
and how big is the crowd you're getting
lost in and on those two monero
currently
um is king that doesn't mean it's going
to be king forever it doesn't mean that
it's
always going to be the the dominant
privacy enhancing technology
uh in the financial space but it is
right now um
and for that alone i think it's uh it's
gotten a fair amount of attention
so i think okay so i firstly love the
analogy it reminds me of an analogy that
i heard i think it was ruben the founder
i think of
z coin um i might be mixing that up but
i think it's right um
so yeah you sort of said to me yeah yeah
yeah ruben yeah
so he's brilliant so he gave me a really
cool analogy and it was something like
um so first steps on a beach basically
so sometimes you just create more
footsteps and then sometimes
you just completely um get the waves to
wash the footsteps away
and i thought okay nice and simple i get
that
so i also want to ask you then what are
your thoughts um
can firstly if we look at things like
mass adoption do you think monero can
scale
number one i'll ask that first do you
think monero can scale
yeah so manero has some interesting
scaling technology
already uh some sometimes simple things
like it's got a dynamic block size limit
so as demand for block space grows
monero's like block size limiter
increases
um and it's got other things like
bulletproofs which has
massively reduced the size of manero
transactions
um so can it scale yes i mean it scales
very differently to bitcoin
but you know there's there's a certain
amount of pruning that pruning that can
be done
to reduce the blockchain storage um
there's dynamic limiters and stuff like
that which
enhances the scale but ultimately i
think that it
there's a there's an upper bound for
both bitcoin and monero
and other uh blockchain systems when it
comes to scaling on chain
and uh and how where that upper bound
lives i think is
is very you know it's it's not sort of
like you can't increase it massively um
ultimately it's always going to be
painful to have
all of these thousands of computers
around the world all storing the same
data and all coming to consensus on it
which is why layer two systems like
lightning and others are so interesting
to me
so talking about scalability there's
sort of no point to talk about
scalability unless
we think that we could actually see um
mass adoption
of privacy coins so the thing with
privacy coins is that
at the end of the day governments for
whatever reason
like to know what you're doing with your
money where your money is whether it's
for tax reasons
whatever it is so we often wonder
whether cryptocurrencies will see mass
adoption where the cryptocurrencies will
eventually
um or maybe they'll be banned but for me
i sort of think okay well
if anything gets banned it's going to be
privacy coins and i'm a huge fan of
privacy coins but i do think that if
anything gets banned it will be privacy
coins so
what do you think do you think that
there's a chance that you know you put
on
all this hard work but eventually it
comes down to the fact that
governments don't allow privacy points
that's a great question so i'm of the
opinion
that um privacy is
not actually like something that
governments necessarily
don't want because at the end of the day
um there's a lot of things that that
governments do
and corporations do which they wouldn't
want exposed and i'll give you a classic
example of this
um there's a lot of government stuff
that is you know out there in the open
but anything that they do that is
clandestine like military
action and in specific parts of the
military
they wouldn't want that to be revealed
by being forced to use a transparent
system
i wanted to jump in though because don't
you think that you know it's often one
rule for them and a different rule for
everyone else so
just so so they could get away
essentially because you know whatever
the government do they've already been
accused of doing so many horrendous
things you know even the british
government in terms of
selling arms to different countries or
whatever but
we as the individual you know basic
person
we don't know even though they're not
using privacy points we still don't know
so
you know they could do what they wanted
for them but for us they've banned it
100 so the way i the maybe maybe a good
way to look at it is uh the
so-called military-grade encryption um
that you you know you sometimes hear
that term in movies it's like
oh we can't crack this message it's got
military-grade encryption
what does that even mean because quite
frankly whatsapp has military-grade
encryption if we if we really want to
get down to it
like you know the the the equip the
encryption that is available
today in open source projects and and
products
and in systems like imessage and
whatsapp and i'm not even talking about
things like wire and signal just normal
messaging systems that people use
is pretty legit and and incredibly
powerful
and has been very well designed and
reviewed by renowned cryptographers and
researchers
um and so the same goes for the
financial systems you know i mean you
can imagine
if if private uh finances are no longer
available if cash is no longer available
then there are certain clandestine
activities
that military that the military might
want to do like paying an informant
that they will no longer be able to do
if cash doesn't exist
then law enforcement can't pay
confidential
informants and that's a big deal so i do
think that
even from a government perspective there
is some degree of privacy
that they want and absolutely i and you
know i'm not
i'm not going to sit here and pretend
that they don't
generally not want privacy they
generally want to
you know be able to control citizens and
so on because
that is the natural state that
regulation tends to right it starts off
with like
everything must be fair and democratic
and then it tends towards control
because it's like a parent right a
parent with an unruly child
when that child is young and it's a baby
and it's all gugu then you know oh it's
so cute
ah did this naughty thing that's just a
naughty little child
and when the child is older and totally
unruly and throwing a tantrum in the
store
well then the parent starts to get a
little bit more manic and uh
and starts to get a little bit more
stern you know and that's that's what's
tended to happen
um and frankly i just i think that just
speaks to
in general it's you know like politics
is something that i i avoid with great
disdain
about the i won't ask you about the
election then i won't ask you no
i i think i think that we're we're it's
we've demonstrated over the past
several thousand years that we're pretty
bad at governing ourselves
you know it doesn't matter we've tried
all sorts of forms of government and
we've just proven that
we're just not good at it um what do you
mean by that
what do you mean by that you know i mean
i
i think that that uh that there hasn't
really been a system of government that
we have we can look at and be like well
that one's really worked you know like
this one has really uh has never there's
been no abuse
of power there's been you know the
citizens are ecstatic with their lot in
life there's no one poor there's no one
hungry
you know if whether it is a monarchy or
a
democracy or you know even the
the sort of more um
centralized forms of government like
ultimately
it's we're just not very good at it and
i think if we if we acknowledge that
then
we we can maybe become a little bit more
self-sufficient
and that's really where cryptocurrencies
are useful
because they allow a little bit more
self-sufficiency they allow a little bit
more self-sovereignty
they allow you to to rely on uh
controlling your own finances instead of
going oh well let's hope that the bank
can
you know bail me out that's hope that
the government can bail me out if things
go wrong
um and i think that that's you know that
sort of
um move towards self-reliance
is what has sparked a lot of uh
cryptocurrency developments it's what
sparked um
it at least seems to be what sparked
satoshi's development of bitcoin
so i have to ask you this um i actually
wasn't planning on asking this but here
we are
um so for me for me
crypto bitcoin is inherently political
for exactly what you've just said so
there's this idea that bitcoin is
apolitical but in my opinion
that is a um a utopian delusion
um and i think we kind of like the idea
that we're like
you know we are opting out of the system
bitcoin is for everyone and anyone and
and and all and all this stuff but it's
exactly what you just said
so it's taking personal responsibility
it's being sovereign
over your own assets and really it's
less government like you said we're not
very good at governing ourselves so
let's govern ourselves on an individual
level and i think that is inherently
political
um given if you look at if you look at
the political the political spectrum
generally you find people um who are
it's very difficult to things of terms
have been hijacked so it's quite
difficult to sort of
explain yeah i was gonna say yeah
you know if you're more let's call it
less cool words like libertarian if
you're more libertarian
then those are your political ideologies
right it's kind of just like
less government intervention and
personal responsibility so i just
inherently think that it's political
what do you think
yeah look i think i think that maybe um
based on a lot of the conversations i've
been having
uh or that i've had over the the past uh
you know nearly a decade with the people
in the space i get the sense that
for the most part what people want is to
be left alone
and they will they will move to another
country
in order to be left alone you know and
that's
that to me is fascinating because it
really
it just shows you that they they're
feeling like
their their space is being encroached on
that that there's regulatory overreach
and the same goes for companies by the
way this is not just an individual thing
i know of plenty of companies that have
either gone
and moved out of a particular country
and i'm not this is certainly not like a
european or a u.s thing it's all sorts
of countries
um i know of companies where at when
they're founding
there's this discussion about where
should we incorporate
yes and they decide way to incorporate
on the basis of
where can we be where we'll be left
alone
you know it's like it's so crazy to
think that like that's the world we live
in
and yet i think it's also nice that
we do have the freedom to be able to do
that i mean you can
start a company open a bank account in a
country you've never even traveled to
and and you know you just ship some
documents to them with wet signatures on
and do everything online everything else
online
and there we go you have a company in
estonia
wait i have a question but like in terms
of having a company in estonia don't you
have to have an
address or something to register under
or am i being
yeah there are there are companies that
will do little proxy offices for you no
problem and they they'll run mailboxes
for physical mail no problem
they will even have someone stop the
phone to pick up the phone
and answer in estonian and english is
this legal this is legal yeah totally
illegal we gotta
there is no illegality with with um
owning a company in another country
you know i mean there might be there
might be tax implications domestically
for you if you do that but that's a
separate issue
so yeah and there are lots of companies
that do this you know i mean you you
think about apple for example
when apple goes into a new country they
they don't necessarily go well we're
going to set up
apple in this country and it's going to
be a wholly owned subsidiary
of apple inc you know there's all sorts
of clever things that they do
but that they sometimes have to do
because you know they they don't
necessarily want to have apple inc
um owning the the china the entity in
china and so on
um so there's all sorts of of things
that typically in the past have only
been available to
large corporations and over the past i
would say the past decade or so
um especially post the panama papers
it's become
a lot easier to do that and cheaper for
individuals
so you know i mean it's um this is the
world that we live in now and it's great
because it's created a
world of regulatory arbitrage you'd want
to set up a company you don't want to
set it up in the country you live in
no problem set it up over there you
don't like the place that you live in
you don't like the laws and whatever no
problem
you can uproot your entire family and
move to another country
it's true i feel that way about the uk i
can't even lie like
taxes um
it's very difficult to be involved in
crypto in the uk there's a lot of
regulatory issues um
only now are we seeing and i say only
now um
10 years down the line or whatever but
still only only now we're seeing
um different companies actually being
available in the uk like crypto.com was
only available you can only really hold
um
pounds and send it to your your sterling
bank account only like i think it was
only
maybe june this year that became
available which is insane
um gemini for example there recently
they've only recently fully opened in
the uk like they have in the us so
a lot of different um regulatory issues
there but yeah i mean
revolut's another another great example
of that where if you have a revolut
account
great you can buy bitcoin and ethereum
and and
ripple and whatever but you can't send
it out your wallet
as bitcoin you have to convert it back
yeah absolutely oh it's so ridiculous
but but i think i think with revolut i
think they're one of those companies
which are
um taking their time with things and
they're sort of doing it in a sen in a
sensible way like i think only they
announced actually last week that you
can now do recurring buys
which is super cool recurring buys and
crypto so that's great except you don't
really have a wallet
to send yes which really doesn't mean
it's just price exposure
but still i like i like that the fact
that revolu i mean revoluts obviously
oh at least i hope they're holding the
the crypto that you buy in the back end
somewhere
and uh you're getting actual price
exposure and not pretend price exposure
but it is it is nice i mean like within
the revolut app you could
you could be a tray a trader you know
small trader but still
um it is it's cool that that exists um
and uh and that it is you know i mean to
sign up on revolut is like a five second
thing it's amazing
yeah my thing with revolut is so i i
love just to move around i i don't
really like to stay in one country
um i love just to move and explore the
world basically so i've i've just fell
in love with revolut from
the fiat perspective actually just
because you get the spot rates you don't
have to change your money like for me
revolut is just unbelievable but for
crypto i really don't recommend it
so if anyone hasn't bought any crypto or
you're watching i just wouldn't
recommend
um at all revenue because also the rates
aren't good
i know they're yeah they're terrible
it's supposed to be decent but it's
absolutely not
like i've seen i've seen like rates on
on revolut that are a good 20
out of uh out of market so yeah i mean
it's
but at the end of the day the
convenience is great and and
i think it's as a soft intro to to
crypto it's been fantastic for a lot of
people
yeah i can't even lie i think i but i
bought so i only got into crypto in 2018
um so two years ago um and
i think i bought my first lot of
whatever i think i bought some xrp
and i bought some bitcoin uh i'm on
revolut back in the day
um yeah but i i sold that and then i
went to coinbase
and then i went to crypto.com that was
kind of my and then
ledger and all that stuff but um yeah so
that was it it was a soft intro i think
even my mom actually bought some um
money on
bought some bitcoin and revolut but now
i've got her on crypto.concept it's all
good but i want to get your thoughts
actually on
um privacy versus um
the possibility of criminal activity
because you know let me
talk about taxes for a second i think
with when privacy coins if privacy coins
come in and it becomes
mass adopted people won't be paying
taxes
from my standpoint you know like i don't
think anybody really pays taxes because
they they want to i think everybody does
it for gradually
um some people see the logic in it some
people see the logic in it but i don't
think anybody's super happy to give
to to pay anything and i was like yeah
take my 20k
nobody like that so i imagine i imagine
that you know if we're dealing with
privacy coins and you could get away
with not paying taxes i wonder
people would do that so and people would
also do more criminal things so
do you think privacy sort of outweighs
um the possibility of illicit activity
you know tax evasion avoidance
sure great questions so i think
the way i like to think of it is um
let's say let's take a typical person
you work for someone
and that company says we can pay your
your um your salary in crypto and you go
oh that's great
fantastic please pay my salary in monero
and they go no problem
they pay your salary but they also have
to report that you are an employee
and this is the salary that they paid
you so the fact that you're being paid
in monero
is great because it means that you
you're able to
um you get that forward privacy you know
and seeing what you're spending your
money on
and so on you have the self-sovereignty
all of that's great but it doesn't
change your tax obligation
okay there's no there's no like uh you
know the tax man doesn't go
doesn't come to you and say like well
your reporter says you're earning ten
thousand dollars a month
but since you don't have a bank account
we're just going to assume you earn zero
you know they're gonna go and like say
well you know this piece of paper
or online thing says that you earn ten
thousand dollars a month
come give us our money and and for you
to deny that you're welcome to deny it
but now it's like your word versus your
your employers uh of course you know
like
like a company might choose to operate
um
in cash just you know and they might
choose to operate
in monero and then they can try and uh
and hide from the tax man and there are
lots of small businesses
all around the world today that are
cash-only businesses especially in
poorer countries
um especially in like africa and parts
of asia
and in fact even in you know america and
europe cash-only businesses
like food trucks where you know a lot of
them just simply do not report taxes
they operate in cash they pay their
bills in cash they pay they staff in
cash
and that is it's like this whole cash
economy
but at the end of the day there are
controls around that right because let's
say that you own
you have a food truck and you're
operating this little cash-only business
and now you want to go buy a car when
you get to the dealer and you're like
here's my big bag of cash that dealer's
like no turn around go to the bank and
deposit us
and when you deposit it at the bank the
bank goes oh we're filing a suspicious
activity report because you're
depositing
you know fifteen thousand dollars in
cash so so the the controls exist
the controls already exist for cash
those same controls can exist for monero
and yes there might be small businesses
that try and
operate under the the tax rate are by
using cash or by using monero or by
using both
and that is between them and the tax man
you know they they
run the risk of being caught and being
fined heavily and so that's not i mean
that just doesn't seem advisable
and i don't think that i don't think
that the existence of monero
suddenly changes the fact that the tax
man can figure out
how much you earn in many instances just
by doing a lifestyle
audit you know they pitch up and they
see the giant house you live in
and the three ferraris they're not going
to believe your claim of only earning
two thousand dollars a month
i hear you i really hear you and i think
that answers my next question which was
because you sort of started off
explaining well hang on we know how much
you earn
because your company had to declare it
whatever so we know leia earns x because
she works for this place and
blah blah blah fine um so then i was
thinking hang on what if i'm
self-employed and i have my own company
and
so on and then i start making all this
money um
but like you said yeah but like you said
you know if you're
living a lavish lifestyle or whatever
you're doing it's going to
raise some some suspicions you know even
if you turn your
even if you turn yeah i mean say the car
dealership what you're saying if there's
a car so say we have
monero mass adoption i want to go buy a
lambo i don't like lambos but let's just
do it for the sake of crypto you know
say i want to go buy a lambo with my
monero you're telling me
that the car dealership would say okay
cool happy to accept your monero
um but they would be a bit oh hang on no
they won't be suspicious of it how would
they know that i haven't
no so they wouldn't be suspicious but
they might uh at least initially there
might be some sort of safeguards like
uh they need to ask you for proof of
funds um or source of funds sorry not
proof of funds
so source of funds is a is a thing that
happens it's an anti-money laundering
thing that happens
um you know i'm sure you've seen people
complain about it
they deposit funds on an exchange they
just they deposit krypton exchange
and the exchange says listen we've
frozen your account you need to
provide source of funds and it's
happened to me in the past it's happened
to a lot of people
and oftentimes it's just as simple as an
email to say
i got this by mining you know or
whatever
and sometimes they they might dig in and
they might say we need a little bit
you know can you can you provide
receipts to show the mining equipment
you bought
you know and yes absolutely i can i know
it bothers you but
at the end of the day like the point i'm
trying to make is a lot of these aml
safeguards exist because of cash
and privacy enhancing currencies like
monero are just a digital
analog or digital equivalent of cash so
those say the same safeguards that exist
for cash exist for manero
they're already there the people know
okay
companies and financial institutions
know how to handle cash
so they actually do know how to handle
monero and yes in in a world where
monero
also privacy and han some other privacy
enhancing currency
is widely adopted or broadly adopted
could some of those safeguards change
absolutely they could change either way
they could become more stringent or less
stringent
but at the end of the day those
safeguards that exist for cash right now
could be used immediately and are used
often
for cryptocurrency in general not even
for privacy enhancing
cryptocurrencies that's really
interesting uh i
that didn't occur to me the slightest so
that's really cool to hear
um i think a lot of people sort of um
have this
um idea that you know in a world of
privacy coins everything is just free
and
we can do what we want
utopian delusion totally because
if you think about it when did
computerized bank accounts really start
to come into
into existence 60s and 70s so prior to
that
it was a world of cash and checks
remember checks
um and if you if you i mean if you if
you think about it like
for the the past few hundred years only
up
only the past 50 years have we really
had this like everything is on the
computer and all your
your financial information is flowing on
the computer like prior to that
it was just a world of cash and ious
and so on now think about how law
enforcement used to operate at the turn
of the century
if they thought someone was laundering
money or doing something illegal
they would actually have to go and
investigate the person
and they there were numerous ways for
them to do to do that
and i think what's happened is with the
computerization of money
law enforcement's almost gotten a little
bit lazy because they go like oh wow
we'll just rely on the banks to tell us
when something suspicious is happening
but i mean you know you walk into a bank
because the the average bank taylor has
certainly not had any law enforcement
training
they have no idea how much bank training
either
you're lucky if they can even process
your transactions so yeah
yeah i mean the total lack of um of
of formal law enforcement training
um in the financial sector is
frightening
and yet those are the people who are
expected to file suspicious activity
reports
so you know it's it's kind of worrying
but i do think again it's an
over correction you know who law
enforcement would have gone from
we know how to deal with with cash to oh
everything's computerized so we can just
sit back and let the banks handle it
hopefully it swings back when if there
is mass adoption of uh
of cryptocurrencies yeah i think that's
really interesting to think
this over correction because it's sort
of you know we're we're moving forward
um in terms of technology and yeah in
some ways in terms of
you can let's call it regulation or laws
or whatever legislation we're sort of
reverting back in some ways because it's
the same
kind of methodology i guess that would
be required for things like cash
back in the day back in the 60s cool so
we are approaching 45 minutes so i want
to get you
to give us a final closing overall
whatever so i'm gonna put you on full
screen it's super complicated
oh that was super easy all right give us
your final words
yeah so i i mean i guess final words are
um
it's 20 20. you know if you survived
this year and i hope that you do
hope that i do too it's time to take
back our privacy and i know that that is
really daunting and i've been saying
this over the past little while and i'm
going to repeat it on the show
take back your privacy one step at a
time start with one service that you use
and switch to a privacy enhancing
service if you use gmail
for email switch to protonmail or to
tonota or some other privacy enhancing
email service
you don't have to get rid of your gmail
you can still use google docs
you can still use all of those other
services but just
switch one thing and try it for six
months and then after six months
switch something else you know so you
use facebook great
switch that off delete your facebook
account and start to use some other
service
or maybe you know pick up the phone and
speak to your friends and
family members and if you can just every
six months
reclaim your privacy by dropping one
service and using a different service or
dropping one app
and using a different app that actually
respects your privacy
you will find that within a few years
you
have just unleashed yourself from
the system that pays where you're the
product and you've gotten into a system
where you're no longer the product
where they work for you where they
defend and protect your security and
privacy
and that is definitely a world that i
want to live in not a world where we
give up all privacy like we're in the
middle of george orwell's 1984.
oh i love that that's so good i totally
agree with you
and i also agree with you turn off your
socials just pick up the phone and speak
to a friend if you do anything this
weekend
speak to a friend pick up the phone
all right fluffy pony ricardo i want to
thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure having you on i want to thank
iconplus for powering it and blockfi
um for sponsoring it so guys i also
think you can don't forget you can get
i've put the link somewhere you can find
it grab your money all right cool
and the broadcast now thanks guys we'll
see you next week
bye